[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is dr. Nicholas Aleph we an expert in
child health and development and former
United Nations director and senior
adviser on the post-2015 development
agenda and more recently director of
programs for UNICEF he is a senior
fellow at the Macmillan center and is
teaching a course on child health and
development in context of sustainable
development he has more than 30 years of
experience in strategic leadership
intergovernmental negotiations child
rights advocacy and programming in
diverse country and regional settings
today we'll talk with dr. le Phooey
about the UN's 2030 agenda for
sustainable development in regard to
child rights welcome doctor thank you
very much so let's start with the
origins of the sustainable development
goals or SDGs as some abbreviate them
and then you know what their purpose is
right at the turn of the century the
millennium affect the world had already
had a series of international treaties
human rights treaties and international
conventions on sustainable development
on Climate etc and it was the perfect
time at the turn of the millennium to
gather around world leaders to decide on
some goals for development in the coming
millennium and so there was a millennium
declaration at the summit that was held
in New York at the turn of the
millennium and along with it we came up
in the UN with those eight millennium
development goals that set global goals
for development mostly in the
socio-economic area and with a provision
for global partnership
to sort of guide the international
effort particularly aimed at developing
countries to accelerate progress that
set the stage for the first 15 years of
the new millennium the sustainable
development goals were established
through a mechanism a mandate that was
established in Rio in 2012 at the summit
Rio plus 20 it was a sort of a
continuation of the sustainable
development summit that I mentioned
earlier the mandate came from there to
establish an open working group and a
mechanism this time much more broadly
consultative and involved in civil
society the academia the general public
in consultations leading to the
establishment of this new set of
sustainable development goals the
framework this time is also more
ambitious because it brings together the
social the economic and the
environmental sustainability aspects of
development and the pinned with
aspirations for peaceful society peace
and security that mentions so it is much
more ambitious it's more integrated and
also it is a universal applies to all
countries not just developing interests
now did it grow out in any way from the
original millennial millennium goals
that were set so there's some overlap of
the goals that were set yes yes maybe
they were there had been a massive
effort during the 15 first years of the
Millennium to accelerate the
implementation on you know eliminating
having extreme poverty reducing child
and maternal mortality rates increasing
enrollment in schools etc
towards the latter half of the 15 year
period we all started to engage in very
intense reviews and analysis of progress
that had been made towards the
Millennium Development Goals and in some
areas the goals were achieved for
example the poverty go okay I'm the
water clean water goal was also okay so
over the course of the 15 years poverty
was I have this great all right but then
we also realized very quickly that the
progress was not equitable we didn't
find evidence that even where there had
been reductions in mortality that the
reductions were happening in the
communities that were most affected or
the most disadvantaged children of women
were benefiting and it became quickly
clear that we were dealing with a
generalized situation of inequalities
and inequity and so equity became the
main focus of the analysis to try and
identify where the most disadvantaged
communities where were the most
disadvantaged and vulnerable children
were and what their situation was during
the drive towards the 2015 most goals
were established in terms of percentage
coverage and so very soon you had you
know achievement in seventy-five percent
coverage eighty percent coverage and the
question became so what's happening to
the twenty percent that's not being
reached because we had been celebrating
eighty percent coverage for you know 10
15 years and so the focus turned to
those most disadvantaged communities for
which new strategies were required new
interventions and approaches were
brought in so the SDGs builds on that
okay that's why for example one of the
key themes of the as the juices on leave
no one behind which is a critical
consideration at the core of the
thinking and the philosophy that it
should we should try and reach the
father's behind
first deliberately right nothing
electrical down process okay so how many
the same sustainable development goals
are there yeah 17 votes total and then
how many I know you're focused on
children how many of those are
specifically aimed at children so all of
the goals including goals related to you
know safe cities and sustainable
consumption climate etc are all related
to your children and future generations
entomology oh really are there any
specific and children it definitely are
there are the they receive for example
the goal related to poverty eradication
this time the sustainable development
goals go beyond what was in the MDGs in
terms of the unfinished agenda it's much
more vicious it aims to eliminate
poverty rather than just reduce it by a
percentage point or the other and we're
looking at another 15 year goal 15 to 20
years t poverty will be a rabbit
eradicated so in 20 you know in 20 30
for example the goals on health and much
more vicious you know the goal on
nutrition also so our vaccines part of
the deep health facts it's a part of
that the elimination of preventable
diseases is included universal coverage
with health services is also included so
yes in health in nutrition in access to
basic sanitation hygiene etc education
and even protection the Millennium
Development Goals didn't have a specific
goal on child protection issues but the
SDGs to have a goal on protection which
aims to eliminate and end all forms of
violence abuse and exploitation and even
torture against children so it's much
more comprehensive and hence the
slightly larger number of goals and
target
I am curious how these goals are going
to be achieved or implemented so how
does the UN work with the rest of the
world to ensure that these goals are met
so the first thing to bear in mind when
it comes to the SDGs is that they are
universal in the sense that there is if
you look at the issue of inequalities
whether you're looking at gender
inequality income inequality or
inequality in terms of access to basic
social services etc you realize that all
countries whether industrialized or
middle income countries or least
developed countries have issues of
inequalities and so the first point is
that the this goals are or this agenda
for the next 15 years is applicable
universally the second is that because
of the focus on tackling the
inequalities that are embedded in our
current development strategies and
approaches there's a huge emphasis on
utilizing disaggregated data in other
words collecting information statistics
that allows you to disaggregate
information to the levels below the
national sample where you can identify
clearly those segments of the community
that have the particular problems that
you want to talk to that in your
strategies and in your resource
allocation you're much more deliberate
and focused in in terms of your
approaches so the use of this aggregated
data will help implementation this time
around thirdly there is a means of
implementation provision in the document
itself through their intergovernmental
negotiations where the Member States
discussed the financing for development
options and how many member states are
there 193 member states so all of them
signed up okay so there are provisions
for financing a particularly domestic
resource mobilization to support the
agenda of course complemented with
international development assistance the
Overseas Development Assistance and
financing for development is built
around the issue of climate economic and
social dimensions and then there is
technology transfer capacity building
training innovation and other forms of
provisions that would allow a global
partnership between the among the
countries that would make it possible
for field level implementation then the
monitoring is established through what
they call the follow up and review
process how often is that done so every
year countries on a voluntary basis will
provide country reports on the processes
and the results that they are able to
record relative to the various goals
there are also thematic reports so you
could take inequalities as a theme on
which countries who are making progress
or facing specific constraints would
report on their country experience
trying to tackle the issue of
inequalities so this dematic reports and
then so you would have national level
reporting done by the countries and
regional commissions would orchestrate
and facilitate regional well part of the
world and then a global report what is
fascinating in the new dispensation is
that there is also an established
mechanism for oversight of the SDGs and
the implementation called the high-level
political forum and whoever prizes that
member states so there is a select
number of member states who sit at this
forum and if they have the ultimate
responsibility to review country reports
identify bottlenecks and work with
members days to try and find solutions
to help countries deal with bottlenecks
and barriers so if someone is falling
behind on their implementation and in
terms of reaching the goals there is
assistance for them yes this should be
theoretically a mechanism through the
high level / the forum where you match
those needs with possible resources from
friendly and like-minded countries and
that is I think one of the exciting
things so if you take the case of small
island developing States so-called seeds
they usually have limited resources with
enormous problems of it related to
climate change adaptation and mitigation
and so they would present the situation
through the country reports or even as a
regional group at the high-level
political firm and then you would have
Member States discuss means of
collaborating and in fact you had
mentioned innovation earlier when you
were speaking can you give some examples
of how innovation can assist in reaching
some of these goals yes definitely
innovations both in terms of technology
as well as those innovations that have
ideas driven so if you take technology
the use of broadband technology for
example made it possible even during the
Intergovernmental process that created
the agenda to reach out to civil society
organizations to general public to young
people we had a we had young people on a
platform the world we want where they
voted on the top priority issues that
they would like they wanted to see
addressed in the new development goals
so the user the deployment of broadband
tech
oh gee to mobilize local communities to
disseminate information about the goals
share best practice and cross fertilize
as it's 11 possibility so many countries
are deploying new forms of technology
and social media platforms to try and
popular eyes and make the agenda famous
and get children and young people
involved so for example they are
teaching about their goals in many
schools as we do here at you there is
the so-called the world's largest
classroom through which all students are
learning same lessons across a hundred
plus countries Wow is that orchestrated
getting young people to read the
child-friendly versions of this dense
documents from the UN and have the
teachers trained on how to explain the
goals two children and what they can do
about it and how they could participate
in their own communities to raise
awareness about climate issues or about
inclusiveness or discrimination etc so
that's that's one possibility the other
possibilities as I mentioned through
technology transfer where you know
you're dealing with digital digital gap
and technology gap between rich and poor
countries etc there is a provision for
example for technology facilitation it's
called the technology facilitation
mechanism through which these developed
countries would work with advanced
economies to try and bridge this gap so
it's not to reinvent the wheel each time
you needed to do something built a
resilient school or or put together some
weather proofing for their communities
so technology and innovation in that
is extremely important to help countries
leapfrog a lot of countries have
wireless you know are even more advanced
in terms of the United States in terms
of their what their mobile cellular
expansion in their countries is that
going to be used in in any capacity
that's exactly what I was referring to
so for example the penetration with SMS
technology short messaging system
technology is very effective in getting
local communities to communicate with
authorities women's groups to
communicate among themselves
cooperatives young people in youth
associations and clubs etc so for
example we are working with some
non-governmental organizations I was
actually going to ask you about that
yeah yes so they are taking target 16.2
which is about ending violence against
children abused exploitation and torture
developing a platform a technology
platform based on SMS and the use of
broadband technology to allow students
in schools and out of school to monitor
how well their child protection systems
are working so for example if there's a
gap between what's supposed to be
happening in terms of bullying in
classrooms etc students are able to use
a platform to communicate the fact that
nothing is being done or a nun boots
person has been established but does not
function effectively etc to allow
authorities to correct these gaps the
use of SMS technology could facilitate
such a platform and when you're using
these technologies you also have the
possibility of aggregating the
information upwards so from several
communities the possibility of learning
from each other etc so yeah this is
these are the things that are exciting
about it
Legend and then in terms of health
initiatives are you also working with
you know health NGOs also in terms of
vaccinations and and getting the word
out through that type of group yes yeah
so for children specifically you know
there are a few really big ambitious
targets that we have in the agenda dead
child poverty there are a number of NGOs
working with un agencies and of course
member states in concerned countries to
try and put in place projects to reduce
and eventually eliminate child poverty
of the billion or so people who live in
extreme poverty in our world today
easily half forty-seven percent half
almost our children so you we do have a
massive problem with child poverty and
then we have the issue of child
mortality and in most cases also
preventable right all right malaria from
malaria diarrhea pneumonia other
vaccine-preventable diseases etc and so
we have a challenge there because we
know what to do it's been done
successfully in other countries so we
need to be able to work together with
concerned countries to particularly
drive down under 5 mortality and within
that that category to focus on newborn
mortality in other words children or
infants dying in the first 28 days of
life which now constitutes about forty
five percent of the under-five mortality
number that is related to maternal
mortality where you have you know the
possibility of dying in childbirth or in
complications related to childbirth in a
place like in West Africa and 0 in
in other places compared to your country
or Norway 16 16 times the chance of
dying giving birth we need to be able to
work on that to reduce that level of is
it because hospitals are not as
prevalent in those areas of the world
and that's the issue so for newborn
health and maternal mortality that's
precisely the problem it had been easier
and to reduce the other forms of
infectious diseases and save lives but
now we're down to those conditions that
require an effective health system not
just a vaccine it's important but it
needs a system to carry it through so
pregnancy is nine month process even
before pregnancy the health of the young
mother etc including adolescent girls
it's extremely important that countries
invest in their health so the duration
attrition especially and their
protection say that we start off in a
way that allows them to survive
pregnancy and childbirth so it's
extremely important to push in those
areas then you know we have things like
HIV malaria tuberculosis those big
diseases that are killers of children
that are in the agenda that we need to
push to eliminate and so you know
malaria tuberculosis HIV are still big
ticket items for HIV is a little bit
more difficult though because there's
also cultural things around that yes yes
you know in all of these issues there is
the underlying issue of the social
determinants and the cultural practices
that booze and customs that drive
certain behaviors and how people local
people perceive or understand what is
going on so in addition to this the
health services we are challenged to
educate society and also social
mobilized
and elevate the health literacy levels
so that people themselves are able to
know what to do like we all do when our
kids for Sigma know what to do etc so
the social aspects and social
mobilization health literacy levels
extremely important technology and
innovation it's important in that area
by disseminating information through SMS
and smartphones to people about these
diseases how to prevent them and what to
do if you get to see a cig sign it's a
very very effective way of communicating
easily with local communities and then
nutrition is the other thing that we we
need to work on for young children in
today's world we still have under
nutrition but this time with an
increasing problem for basically as well
insurance oh you have a double burden in
industrialized countries as well as in
developing countries that we need to
work on so there are some big things for
children that we need to hit yeah moving
forward and it sounds very ambitious any
well it is and the hope is that
countries will get together to pull
assets and resources to be able to get
some traction it is absolutely clear to
me that the new agenda cannot be
implemented single-handedly by any
ministry or department of health or
education or by a government in
isolation it requires and there is
provision in the 2030 I'd gender for
sustainable development for for that
level of partnership a global
partnership that allows countries to
pool resources and create some synergies
because they are because of the ambition
level it's beyond the scope of any
undies is exactly so let's talk about
the class you're teaching here at Yale
what are you what are you teaching
your students in terms of how they can
make a difference in this process so the
first semester was devoted to the
origins of the SDGs and agenda 2030 we
discussed where the whole notion of
sustainable development comes from and
how the three dimensions the
socio-economic environmental
sustainability aspects connect with the
peace and security underpinnings and to
create a framework that is universally
accepted as you know the agenda was
universally adopted and September last
year by all the heads of state at the UN
as did you submit so we've gone through
that we've discussed the financing
arrangements through the means of
implementation processes that I was
outlining earlier and have been
discussing how the implementation will
be done and you know how countries would
go through a process of translating
these global goals international
development plans and making them
actionable at country level through a
process of mainstreaming so the
mainstream the SDGs into the national
development plans we identify areas
where there needs to be accelerated
action so it will be acceleration there
and then policy support for
international cooperation so that
partnerships can be formed within the
country as well as externally plus
raising the resources through the budget
process and country to support and then
identifying gaps that may be other
countries can help so there's a process
of what we call Maps mainstreaming
acceleration policy support and
financing arrangements and that's
ongoing and then the data aspects we've
also looked at partly we went to the UN
to pay a visit so the students could see
some live sessions going on and I
appreciate the complexity of
intergovernmental mechanisms and the
processes and it was very very useful
next semester we are going to be
devoting much more time to dealing with
the technical substantive aspects of
child health and development so this
time we've been understanding SDGs MDGs
you know primary health care strategy is
a concept notes so we're going to go in
depth depending on the area of study of
the students we will select specific
areas for them to research into link
them up with willing and like-minded
institutions some of them in the UN
others in the non-governmental sector
who are doing work in this area and they
learn from them during the second
semester so at the end we will have a
full understanding of the SDG process as
well as the technical aspects of how
child health and development aspects
will actually be implemented monitored
and reported on from the field okay
great sounds like very important work
and I thank you for being here today
thank you very much indeed sure for more
information about dr. le puy and his
research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you
[Music]
you